[Applaudissements]
vous avez peur tant mieux comme ça je
vais pouvoir vous expliquer ce qui se
passe quand vous avez peur vous pouvez
avoir une augmentation de votre
fréquence cardiaque
peut-être vous avez sursauter vous avez
peut-être mieux orienter votre regard
pour déterminer d'où venait ce cri ou
encore cela qu avoir provoqué des
changements dans vos expressions
corporelles ou bien faciale alors à quoi
servent tous ses réflexes
le mot émotions vient de mg au vert en
latin ce qui nous met en mouvement et du
coup un état émotionnel va changer vos
prédispositions à percevoir et à agir de
façon la plus adaptée à une situation
prenons l'exemple de l'expression
faciale de peur il a été montré que
cette expression faciale va permettre
non seulement d'augmenter notre champ
visuel pour mieux percevoir ce qui se
passe à la périphérie mais aussi
d'augmenter notre volume nasale face à
un danger nous avons besoin de
comprendre ce qu'il se passe et
justement cette expression faciale va
nous permettre d'acquérir plus
d'informations sensorielle sur notre
environnement
mais est ce le cas pour toutes nos
expressions faciales et bien non si nous
prenons par exemple l'exemple du dégoût
celle inverse
il s'agit pourtant aussi d'un danger
mais d'une tout autre nature et du coup
l'expression de dégoût contrairement à
l'expression faciale de peur va
permettre de fermer tout mécano sociaux
sensorielle la bouche le nez les yeux
afin de me protéger et d'éviter tout
contact entre ce qui a provoqué cette
émotion le dégoût et mon corps donc les
expressions faciales émotionnel ont une
fonction très importante pour celui ou
celle qui l'expriment l'aider à répondre
à son environnement au mieux au cours de
l'évolution ces expressions sont devenus
des signaux de communication une petite
ouverture pour les autres sur mon nez
émotionnel un système de communication
c'est un signal qui transmet une
information importante pour notre
interaction sociale et qui a pour but de
changer le comportement de l'autre mais
ce signal au cours de l'évolution n'a pu
perdurer que si l'observateur à la
capacité justement de décoder cette
information importante mais surtout
d'adapter son comportement en
conséquence
alors comment le cerveau des côtes ils
ces signaux sociaux
très schématiquement si je vous présente
un objet comme il celui ci l'information
va être transmise des yeux au cortex
visuel en passant par le thalamus et
ensuite cette information va être
transmise à deux voies en parallèle
d'une part la voix ventrale qui va vous
permettre de reconnaître que cet objet
est une tasse et d'autre part à la voix
dorsale qui va répondre à deux questions
où se situe cet objet par rapport à moi
et comment puis je l'utilisé et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que la simple
perception de cette taxe va engendrer au
sein de votre voix dorsale la
préparation en parallèle de toutes les
actions que vous pourriez réaliser sur
cet objet par exemple apprendre par la
ans si vous avez envie de boire ou bien
la prendre par dessus si vous avez
besoin de la nettoyer notre corps texte
note voix dorsale nous permet donc
d'anticiper en permanence les
interactions possibles que vous pourriez
avoir avec votre environnement présent
alors maintenant on va complexifier un
peu la scène et dans notre chaîne on va
rajouter une personne en 1992 les
neurones miroirs ont été découverts au
sein de cette même voie dorsale et ses
neurones ont la particularité non
seulement d'être actif quand je saisis
cette tasse mais aussi quand je regarde
quelqu'un prendre cette taxe pourquoi et
bien non seulement peut-être pour
comprendre les actions d'autrui mais
surtout pour les anticiper
dans cette scène si la tasse et près de
l'autre
votre cerveau va anticiper que peut-être
il aurait envie du café avant même
il est commencé ou fini son geste et du
coup vous pourrez prendre la cafetière
face à vous et le servir sans hâte va
avoir à attendre sinon imaginer la
lenteur de nos interactions alors le
problème c'est qu'il y avait plus de
café et ce jour là
votre collègue ils avaient très mal
dormi et du coup il se met très en
colère si mes neurones miroirs pourrait
permettre de comprendre son état
émotionnel
ils ne sont pas suffisants pour que je
réponde de façon adaptée à cette
situation la colère va être traitée par
la voix dorsale pour m'aider à décider
quelles actions je dois adopter dans
cette situation pour mieux vous
expliquer on va faire un petit test
je vais vous présenter une scène comme
celle ci sur laquelle il y a quatre
chaises les deux chaises du milieu sont
occupés et les deux chaises deux à
l'extérieur sont libres et je vais vous
demander de bien fixer le point rouge au
milieu et quand ce ensuite de me dire
sur quels chefs vous auriez envie de
vous asseoir on fait un essai fixé bien
le point rouge
on y va où vous aimeriez vous asseoir à
droite ou à gauche
ok on fait un deuxième essai fixé bien
hélas très bien donc dans le laboratoire
nous avons fait cette expérience sur
plusieurs personnes plus d'une trentaine
mais contrairement à vous ils n'ont pas
réalisé deux fois ce choix mais presque
mille fois mes skis cézanne nous a
permis de montrer c'est que de façon
générale les gens vont préférer la
chaise qui leur permet d'être le plus
loin possible de quelqu'un qui exprime
la colère alors même qu'il n'avait pas
forcément perçu que les personnages
exprimer une émotion au niveau cérébral
la colère va être traitée très
rapidement par l'amygdale qui est le
centre des émotions et qui va
transmettre cette information
en moins de 200 millisecondes
c'est-à-dire un cinquième de seconde
non seulement à la voix ventrale pour
lui dire attention il y a dans
l'environnement quelque chose
d'important qu'il faut que tu comprennes
mais aussi à la voix dorsale pour lui
dire qu'il va bientôt falloir agir
mais il ne s'agit pas ici de réflexes
comme tout à l'heure quand vous avez
entendu le cri il s'agit d'une décision
entre plusieurs actions et en fonction
de la situation
donc si je reviens à mon café face à la
colère de l'autre et sans fontanes et
ment sans vraiment réfléchir je peux
décider soit de me lever et de refaire
du café mais je pourrais aussi décidé de
me mettre en colère donc nos émotions
influencent nos décisions à tout moment
et souvent de façon inconsciente et cet
influent simplicité de bonnes choses
elle nous permet de naviguer de façon
fluide dans notre environnement social
qui est complexe et d'adapter très
rapidement notre comportement on peut
prendre l'exemple par exemple d'une rue
bondée ou pire encore à paris de la
station châtelet aux heures de pointe
notre capacité à anticiper les gestes
d'autrui en permanence va nous permettre
de ne pas trop bousculer les autres et
de ne pas être bousculé sans avoir
vraiment à réfléchir à nos gestes et en
parallèle notre système émotionnel va
nous permettre d'être vigilant en
détectant à tout moment des indices qui
pourraient mettre à mal notre survie et
en influençant nos décisions alors
maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe si on
est confronté non pas individuellement
mais collectivement à une menace réelle
il existe dans notre société une idée
bien ancrée
selon laquelle dans ce genre de
situation les gens vont paniquer et du
coup ils vont adopter des comportements
qu'on dit individualiste c'est à dire
pratiquement aux dépens des autres par
exemple les poussées pour assurer leur
propre survie
mais cette idée n'est que partiellement
vrai avec guillaume des oeufs cash nous
avons réalisé une experts nous avons
interviewé des survivants du bataclan
pour essayer justement de comprendre
quelles stratégies comportementales
étaient mises en place face à un danger
vraiment réel comme c'était le cas pour
cela nous avons écouté l'ensemble des
interviews et nous avons codé chaque
action
qui avaient été réalisées ou vu et ce
qu'il en ressort c'est que les gens vont
adopter ont adopté plus souvent des
comportements pro sociaux d'entr'aide
vers les autres que des comportements
individualistes donc en situation de
menace réelle ou ma vie est en danger
il semblerait que les comportements de
soutien social soit maintenue il nous
reste encore beaucoup de travail pour
comprendre la complexité de ces
comportements sociaux mais j'espère que
ce soir je vous ai montré que de façon
spontanée sans avoir à réfléchir
on va tout le temps englober l'autre et
ses gestes dans notre espace d'action et
que nos émotions ou celle d'autrui
participe à part entière dans nos
décisions entre les différentes actions
qui sont possibles dans cet
environnement pas toujours pour notre
bénéfice mais aussi pour le bien-être
des autres
merci
[Applaudissements]